looking to reassure people in indonesia
the government live streamed president
joko widodo getting the country's
first chinese cenovak covet 19 vaccine
last week
the first nation outside of china to
grant emergency use
some neighboring countries in southeast
asia will do the same over the coming
weeks and months
thailand malaysia singapore and the
philippines have all placed orders
this despite a wide range of data on its
efficacy from the early trials of the
vaccine
from 91 percent in turkey to 50.4
percent in brazil
just barely above the world health
organization's cutoff at 50 percent
some southeast asia countries are
reviewing orders and have not yet
approved the jab this has led to some
questions about the vaccine stemming
from the lack of transparency
and data from the chinese firm and
reluctance to give information to
regulators in the u.s
europe and the w.h.o the chinese
regulators
do not want to give up the control so
if they would submit their vaccine
dossier to
one of these the fda in the united
states the ema in europe
or the who pre-qualification process
they would give up a certain amount of
control
he went on to say that even with the
lower numbers the vaccine will still
help
stem infection rates and the cenovac
inoculation might be better suited to
some nations in southeast asia that
don't have the infrastructure
to keep more advanced vaccines
supercooled cenovac is based on an older
vaccine technique using
killed virus particles to build people's
immunity
while the pfizer biontec and moderna
vaccines are more effective
they use a newer method utilizing part
of the coronavirus's genetic code
to train the immune system to attack
thailand is looking to start vaccinating
high priority people with the cenovak
jab
next month in light of the efficacy
numbers thai officials have requested
more information
but are moving forward with their
vaccine rollout some here
feel as though the lack of transparency
around the vaccine is not limited
to trial data thai strategy so far is
banking on cyanobac
and a bit untransparent a bit of
conflict of interest where you have a
major thai conglomerate the the cp group
taking a stake in a company that
produces a cyanovac
and you know this this raises a lot of
questions for for thai society in thai
public health
like some of its neighbors thailand is
ordering vaccines from other companies
as well
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine should
arrive by may
it will then be produced here for local
and regional export
later in the year scott heidler al
jazeera bangkok
let's get more on this we're going to
talk to ali phatom he's a vaccinologist
and vice president
of vaccine research and development at
blue willow
biologics he joins us from ann arbor
michigan in the united states ali phatom
welcome to the newshour
what's the issue what's causing the
issue here with the efficacy of the
chinese vaccine
yeah thank you for the uh invite uh the
these vaccines as you know it's a full
is a
full virus a whole virus that is killed
and inactivated
and of course this is the traditional
way of making vaccines
there is a lack of numbers a lack of
information of loaf information
uh it's also is the what we are getting
from these trials is really a general
statement rather than
detailed outcomes for safety and also
for efficacy
so as you can see we are seeing
different performances in different
countries and this is really
somehow uh strange i think that uh
we need to see more information
uh and it's not like it's a suspicion
but at least to know what
is going on in these trials because
those numbers between 50 and 90 percent
it makes us wonder you know exactly how
these studies were run
what is the population that was tested
in
and also what is the efficacy across the
board you know with the
different uh uh ages uh
so those are kind of um information that
with western standards is really uh
did not meet those those standards so
okay therefore we are really
looking for that just to be clear if the
success rate is 50.4 percent
in uh countries in latin america that is
point zero four of a percent too close
to the who's reaction which would be
not wishing to put words into amounts
what's the point if the fail rate
then tips into being a fail rate instead
of being a success rate why bother why
not just give somebody
another vaccine i i think we have to
look at this objectively
uh when we say 50 percent if you look at
the
influenza vaccine the infection the
efficacy of the influenza vaccine which
everyone is taking is about
between 30 and 50 percent it never
really exceed that
in the last 20 years so basically uh
the ability to protect at 50 percent
add to that the fact that there was
almost no severe or ma or mild
infection in these people so meaning
that
you are not preventing the the infection
totally
but you are really protecting against
severe disease
and against mortality and against
other diseases so therefore uh
preventing severe disease is also an
advantage and therefore we cannot just
discard
uh the uh you know the baby with the
dirty water we need to look at this
as uh an achievement and especially we
are talking here about
uh a full uh virus homogenate or
inactivated vaccine
that will give a good immunity so
therefore i don't really discount that i
think it's
uh it's an advantage and we should take
care of that especially under the
circumstance of an epidemic
okay uh ali when i've got you there can
i get your opinion on
a european aspect of the vaccination
program
some several european countries are
going down the same road now they
started
about six or eight weeks ago their
starting point was we will vaccinate the
population of this country once
then we'll follow it up with another
vaccination three weeks later
various governments are now saying
actually it might be several months
later
does that mean in the intervening
several months instead of three or four
weeks
people are less protected than they
would have been had they had
two vaccinations separated by 21 days
that's a very good question and i think
that uh looking at the data from the one
immunization we've seen that there is
about an efficacy of about 80 percent
around 80 percent with one immunization
and that's probably will will continue
to be around
for months and therefore spacing the
immune
the second injection or second
immunization
by two months or three months it could
even have some advantage
so by protocol we have to give it
everything
three weeks interval but
if you look at the uh practically and
immunologically
it could be an advantage even to uh
delay the second dose to one month or
two months or three months
so i don't believe that there will be
any issue with regards to the efficacy
or
increasing a risk for the population who
will take one and then
two months or three months later gets a
second immunization
i think this is really a practical and
uh realistic approach to
the pandemic and the need which is a
huge
out there and that could be a very smart
uh approach
that's a really interesting point to
draw a conversation to a close alifat on
there at ann arbor michigan thank you so
much
thank you